today we're going to pay homage to our
presidents we're going to honor one of
my favorite presidents president
Theodore Roosevelt he led the first
United States volunteer Cavalry during
the Spanish-American War
and his unit was known as the Rough
Riders today there will be no signature
blades in your signature style instead
we'll be giving you in peace of W1 round
stock from wish to forge this
a roughrider's buoy
issued to everyone in the Rough Riders
unit today you'll be making exacting
copies of that blade good luck blade
Smiths your three hour Starts Now
my name is Dan burlodis I'm from
Taylorsville Kentucky I am a
metallurgical engineer I really look at
Metallurgy and Material Science being an
engineer as kind of the other side of
the same coin as bladesmithing
bladesmithing is very important to me
because it is this Perfect Blend of Art
and Science and skill
power hammer is a fantastic piece of
equipment but it is really really easy
to get carried away and while hammering
I see something at the very last two
inches of my blade
it's a cold shot the best thing to do is
just get the angle grinder out and grind
off that excess
I grind away the cold shut it's a little
deeper than I'm expecting but I still
have a good amount of material there but
I had to stretch out a little bit more
material than I was comfortable with so
now I'm looking at a heat treat on an
edge that's a little thinner than I had
wanted
so I think to myself I need to Edge
Quench and that's it
you can go for an edge Queen which which
is very clever
my name is John Sims I'm a 21 year old
hobbyist bladesmith when I'm foraging
I'm just in my own little world being a
quiet and software spoken individual
people tend to think that I'm
I'm really not just come approach me
I'll talk to you for hours I have to
reach this two inch width requirement so
I'm working off the side of the dies
just widening everything really nice I'm
going to continue to spread this
material out a little more until I get
just over the two inch marks so I have
meat to play with when I go to the
geyser John's blade looks alarmingly
short just have to hope that I can
stretch it enough to make the length
requirements
I'm at the grinder I've hogged off all
the material I think I need to hog off
before I quench my blade being that I
don't have a lot of experience with W1
I'm not sure what it's going to react to
the quench light
feeling kind of apprehensive kind of
nervous I do not want this to go wrong
the quench I checked the blade for
straightness it's fairly straight I
don't see any major warps
my name's Josh nicolinas the reason why
I started blade smithing is because I
was practicing a lot of survival skills
and all the scoreboard knives that I had
just turned out to be junk so I figured
I could make my own my friends would
describe me as the goofy redneck from
down the road I would describe me as the
goofy redneck down the road
Josh is drawing his steel out lengthwise
so you really want to follow it to win
what are the best ways to folder here
blue has full ring dies and you have to
go at it from right angles which isn't
happening
working my steel I'm feeling good about
the length and then it had gone
something that I have to make this two
inches wide as well
Josh he's been struggling a little bit
trying to make the width he now has a
very thin blade he's at the grinder
I'm in a Mad Dash Street that's done at
times flying by
so now I'm getting ready to quench this
W1 Steel
gosh it's in the quench right now
I can tell that there is a warp to it I
have forged it out too thin trying to
meet that two inch wide parameter
and I've picked up a warp three two
one
blade Smith shut down your machines drop
your tools this first round of
competition is over
all right blade Smiths it's time to turn
your blades into fully functional Rough
Rider buoys by attaching handles to them
he provided you each with buffalo horn
scales from which to construct your four
pin coffin handle blades with file work
liners and Brass guards with lobes good
luck your three hour Starts Now I cut
out the brass and now what I need to do
is make a slot for my tank
I need to put some decorative file work
on the brass liners Dan is uh just going
at his file work with that Dremel now I
need to start gluing off my pieces
together I'm relying on it to be curing
while I'm sharpening my blade
I have to put a guard on this knife with
lobes my guard at the moment is a little
long I know I need to remove material on
it
oh boy I cut off all this material on
one side instead of both I don't have
enough material to make a lobe on one
side my guard isn't shaped I don't have
these lobes it's probably still too long
so I have to go to the grinder rough in
these lobes and then rough in the handle
it doesn't look exactly like the Rough
Rider buoy and it's a replication
challenge
I'm kind of shaking in my boots at this
point about it
I know I have issues in my tank it's
entirely too long so I take it over the
anger Grider and I chop a big piece off
I get all the measurements drawn onto my
piece of brass for my guard
I drill some pilot holes so that I know
where I need to get my Tang through
I'm grinding away on this handle and I
realize I have a gap between my handle
material and my guard oh
my guard just came loose
I've got an epoxy everywhere yep
thankfully it's in the Gap where I
needed it to be done I'm gonna step back
from it that's it is what it is it's all
I can do to it five four three two one
blade Smiths drop your tools stop what
you're doing this second round of
competition is over
I'm looking at my competitor's blades if
mine just doesn't look as pretty I'm
hoping that it'll outperform theirs and
maybe the looks will come second
blade Smiths welcome to the strength
test the Moose antler chalk remember
this test is all about what the antler
does to your buoys and not what the
Rough Rider buoys do to these moose
antlers
Dan you're up first you ready yes sir
all right
I'm really worried about the moose
antler chop because it's such a brittle
hard material and it can crack or Dent
an edge very very easily
[Music]
thank you
well then first things first this Edge
held up perfectly there's no plunting
rolling chipping one small issue there's
a little piece of the handle that comes
up right here and it's Sharp
in general really well done thank you
John you're up you ready yes sir
there are gaps in my handle and that
could pose some issues in the back of my
mind I'm thinking that the handle could
just fly apart
thanks
foreign
[Music]
a couple things happened first and
foremost your guard is is quite loose
in the testing your Edge took
a roll that you can hear here
in all I mean it's it's one knife
instead of two which is great and uh
it's got a great look to it so well done
thanks sir
Josh
you're up you ready
doesn't matter no okay okay
so they've tested Dan's blade they
tested John's John took a little bit of
damage but nothing that was catastrophic
now they're onto mine and I'm worried
[Music]
well Josh first things first there's
some serious gaps on both sides between
the handle material and the guard aside
from those issues the blade held up
perfectly well done thank you
oh
late Smith welcome to the sharpness test
the fish slice Dan you're up first you
ready yes sir let's do this
[Music]
well we got four Stakes out of it
beautiful job
it is sharp there's a spot here in the
garden it could have been smoothened out
but it did not affect the use of your
Blade the balance of your blade is good
and most importantly it will cut good
job sir thank you John you ready yes sir
foreign
[Music]
ER Bowie right here first up on the
first cut then cut all the way through I
just ran out of Blade but on the
subsequent cuts it is sharp an overall
sir your blade it will cut thank you sir
all right Josh your turn you ready do it
do it let's do it
[Music]
all right Josh let's talk about your
blade here first up is the handle
it feels like it should be held this way
because it's offline
and in one of the cuts it did affect the
way I was indexing my hip with the guard
and then into the blade but this is a
sharp blade and
it will cut that's awesome that's all I
wanted to hear
blade Smiths we asked you to make Rough
Rider buoys to honor President deodor
Roosevelt
the judge's deliberation is complete
they've made a final decision only two
of you can move forward into the finale
one of you blade Smiths has to leave the
forge Glade Smith leaving the forge is
[Music]
John
your blade didn't make the cut David
Baker's got to tell you why
John this decision came down to the
strength test in which your blade picked
up a rolled edge and a loose guard
making it the only blade that took any
damage
John please surrender your buoy
my only real regret is that the handle
just didn't hold up the guard didn't
hold up I would have worked better on
the handle
I came here to prove to myself that I am
working down the right path of my
craftsmanship
and I believe I've proved that to myself
under these conditions
foreign